into the corner it goes where borren gets
tied up by Yanni hackin pom Matt duchaine
comes out he's got a two-on-one with Sean
duchaine across the line to Sean Duane he
scores more Magic from that Trio and Duane
and San put together a work of art to open
the score ing well it it's an ill advised
pinch by borgan the defenseman but Mason
Marchman does good work to chip it past him
once they do that duchan to Sean to Duane and
they had Joey dord swimming in that crease
area the pass should never get through once
let alone twice but it does against alexc the
blocked in rof Yanni gour couldn't get it past
to Shane who's got the lone goal here early
on cracking across the Blue Line shot by bjor
strand rebound chance Wedgewood fought it off
and he's down and he is in a lot of pain Matt
Murray who has been called up from the Stars
American his goal moves it to an individual
four game point streak he's got points at six of
the last seven what a glove save by dord got that
right in his glove dord got a beat on it got
out and jumped on the tape of mccan stars turn
it over Yamamoto back for mccan centering pass
off the Stick of Wedgewood Robertson deflected
still muscled out to Center hits knocked down
FedEd on Peli has help Robertson his shot he
scores it's another Rush goal this one from
Jason Robertson to love yeah all that for
checking pressure by the Kraken but they they
linger or loiter up ice a little too much the
stars in transition pavelski just lays it straight
through alexc again and you have responsibilities
you try to keep the puck on one side and Robertson
slips it tweeners on De Court as they have just
eaten the former the other one you were talking
about Johnson Ball battle continues Ben helping
to pluck it free chipped out G donov he'll race
in trying to turn around done shot and it's saved
by Dort coming back in the lineup is that these
scoring goals as you mentioned also even they
not getting scored off over to suder back for hkin
in one Tim that one Ricochet over to the sidewalk
turned over and in comes bers he's got tar bers
shot save rebound and it's scored Tatar it just
had enough a little trickler through Wedgewood
at 32 seconds into the second Tomas Tatar has
his first with the Kraken that's the start I'm
sure they talked about between periods Ryan Suter
fell down in neutral ice that opened up a hole
for Tatar to get to the net I don't think this
Puck goes in later in a period and if it doesn't
get up on its end but it's slick ice it's on end
and rolled its way over the line impotent Agony
for the stars to try to pull that out of there
you can see Miro hkin and late to the party you
have to control it if you're the defensive team
before the whistle comes Seattle hasn't done
that yet pelski Lindell crowd reigning their
Applause exhausted players out there but
the stars have the book angle du Shan he
scores
yeah they basically just Juiced the orange
here they're cracking trying to fill leg
what a lovely cross ice incisive pass by
pavelski I think everybody on the Kraken
anticipated Joe was going to feed it to
the point he tucked his shoulder it was
a wide open Lane to the one-time for to
Shane who did it back in the first stars
on the attack steel and then Smith the followup
kicked out to court starts to settle for more
six on fives way things went earlier this
period sharp ble shot from Lindell missed
the net weird and hackin Pa gets there Everly
steals it though has helpen fed there Baner
scores it was an over skate giveaway way in
the star Zone winds up an odd man rush and
Matty bers has the Kraken back within a goal top
of the circles in Opportunity when Dell was down
deep the stars did not exactly hustle back into
their own Zone as forwards there was a delay I
think anticipating that hawen F was going to be
able to do something with that puck they change
the point of attack a lot of real estate for
Wedgewood to get over and an exploding awarded
he lost his stick and everything else he had
that trophy wrapped up in the early part of
last year Robertson shot in and out of the
glove of dord and stays wide just six Power
Play Goals in 14 games since delay of game puck
over the glass hkin in here's Yamamoto and a
shot fought off by the Blocker of Wedgewood
Pete dor is asked about his penalty kill he
talks about more than just the percentage but
time up of it there's a tip save made rebounds
loosened swatted wide rebound again Wedgewood
got over to deny TANF Everly in the left wing
side up to the point done 25 seconds left bork
strand off the bar stays out and tolven in
scores Ellie tolven in ties the game with 21.8
seconds to go the first shot hit iron and the
net mouth scramble converts for Seattle point
of the tying goal is along the boards the Stars
forwards had multiple opportunities to get
it out and couldn't do it long floater off
the pipe mad scramble in front Stars don't win
that battle there was contact on on Wedgewood
on the initial shot whether it's enough to to
question it or was shoved in there but they
did not win the inner slot battle and we are
22 seconds away from going to overtime which
decord their net minder tonight that's
all he does it feels like as we enjoy
freeberg after League initiated
review we do have a good goal on the
ice some fresher legs for the Kraken Larson
hands in AC cross bers and then makes his way
to the bench here's bers darting left side
a shot off the outside of the post there was
space for him and just off iron yeah and
there was a little hitch in the delivery
there that I think messed things up done
is the Kraken again in bers curling behind
in that wrap around Wedgewood got over to
make the save stars have never trailed in
the contest led by as many as two a couple
of occasions here's Harley back to Du Shane
two goals in the game he waits and in front
score he put it right on the tape of Thomas
Harley overtime winner for Harley Stars beat
the Kraken 4 to3 rer Evans who was out here
in overtime and his responsibility was the
other defenseman and once duain got it Matt
just stood there and he was wide open heavy on
his stick duchaine delivers it Matt duchaine
with a couple of goals in the game and then the
architect of an overtime dagger bam Ender another
goal for Harley who has been absolutely
fabulous in that category just leaned on
the stick to make sure that hot pass didn't
blow up off of it you'd see him lean Direct